okay
okay we're in
okay it's on
okay thank you thank you so much oh let
me give you some bashish bushish
[Music]
i was told jeddah is more liberal and
more open
and
that was a great example so i walked in
the hotel i was
i was pretending to take footage of the
hotel and i asked her
neva could i turn the camera around and
she was totally cool with it
and she was great right just big open
smile
and so it does feel more open here feels
more liberal and it feels
very diverse
[Music]
thank you my friend
thank you
you're telling me
[Music]
cruise around jeddah saudi arabia and
we're lucky enough to have abdullah
as her faithful god
very fascinating place
very much mixed up
very
cultural in the sense that there we just
saw a group of filipino bikers
indonesians
indians pakistanis syrians
i think there are two narratives for
people that don't know about saudi which
is pretty much everyone
i think the two narratives of
one is everyone's on a camel
okay and it's just sand
and the other is
everyone's just dripping in oil wealth
and super rich yeah
what do you what do you think it is it's
neither both i mean uh they are just
normal like every place
you have
the middle class the upper class
the lower class your income tax is what
what do you pay for income tax
zero the income tax the whole live music
thing
here
just started right
well people here used to go out and go
out after the country to attend live
concerts okay
but now uh they are welcoming these
concerts here
yeah they they invited many uh artists
including uh nicki minaj but she didn't
come
janet jackson she came he said okay one
thing i've liked about saudi
is
it's not a drinking culture at least on
the outside
so people are
they're entertaining themselves in a
different way in the west quite often
the entertainment
is revolved around our alcohol bars
i'm not a drinker i quit four years ago
four or five years ago
yeah man
no judgment no judgment against drinking
it's just nice
to be an environment where the the focal
point
is not drinking exactly
morning brother
[Music]
salam
[Music]
when does this fill up when do these
places get busy
weekend nights nights yeah yeah and also
today it can be after the prayer
[Music]
[Music]
okay so you're you're from riyadh
originally but you live in and
when did it start where like
you could come out here alone as a woman
drink your coffee you're working on a
spreadsheet
when did that start happening
here
[Music]
i believe it starts happening way before
i start doing it the idea of me going
out
um
without having a kid that job or
anything
i was i was scared to do that because i
thought that
you know negative things will happen to
me actually when i start doing it like
nothing happens you know it's like i am
i'm feeling something that is not here
for you to
to do what you want
and let others do what they want
right so is it
your very your younger twenties right
yeah okay
so is it a very exciting time for the
youth right now it's really really
really exciting yeah so there are lots
of opportunities you know yeah maybe
in your country or in your own you know
uh in your communities you hear about
all of these people who who started
things you know who are the ones to do
the first one to do this or the first
one to do that right you know that
happened maybe in your dad's generation
but in our case this will happen in our
relationship so i get to be the first
one to do something i get to be the one
who's
changing the narrative you know wow
that's exciting someone said that saudi
arabia is a place where people who know
about it don't speak about it and people
who speak about it they really don't
know about it
[Music]
[Music]
they used to walk from the port way down
there yeah all the way up here all the
way to mecca yeah which is how far
makkah is like
driving one hour so you can imagine
in the heat this is this is no joke here
people are living in these are now
right now not all the buildings right
some of the buildings
this whole old town old city
is just an adventure of going down
different
windy alleyways labyrinths
and then seeing
that
beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
happy birthday
[Music]
huh
[Music]
it's like two different worlds
completely yeah
from the mega shopping malls and like
all the modern coffee shops yeah and
this is old world it feels like this is
where everything started abdullah will
not let me pay for anything he's paid
for
lunch desserts
dinner last night
he's very sturdy he's actually you're
more stubborn than me
you're more stubborn than me bro i'm
ready i'm pretty stubborn
because i've tried to pay
it's in the culture here though right
like an arab would it be is it an arab
thing or is it a saudi thing no it's an
arab thing right like the guest does not
pay for things yeah to some degree yes
yeah so prophet um
because this was available in medina
where you live
so he used to clean his teeth so every
period of the prayer he used it
every prayer he uses
what do i do just chew on it
yeah so you do like this
on your thumbs feels good
[Music]
that's an interesting combination
mall culture is going off here
and so on the hot days
in jeddah
which is well [ __ ] every day it's hot
midday
nobody's on the streets
everybody's in these mega malls
one of the reasons i wear this is i need
protection from the sun
and it's actually it's actually quite
comfortable it's like way better than a
baseball cap which i don't like
and another reason is
well it confuses people here so if i if
i go without
i just look like some
military american guy which i'm not i am
american but i'm not in the military
but if i wear this
it confuses people
and so
they think i'm either from egypt
syria or from the balkans
yeah it's it's it's like very
interesting how i'm received with this
versus without like positive both ways
but from a different different look hey
[Music]
here's a little cultural detail as they
close
businesses for prayer time
i'm trying to get into this coffee shop
i think it's like
20 30 minutes at a time
and then once the prayer time is over
everything opens green coffee and we
roast the coffee ourselves
so we get from
different origins latin america africa
uh i mean we get from yemen as well does
yemen have good coffee
it has one of the best coffees really
yeah in the world and we roast the
coffee and this is our own brand it's
not a franchise or anything nobody knew
how it's going to be
three years ago
but now i mean it's
everyone is quitting their jobs and
they're starting businesses whether it
was you know coffee shops
services
you're telling me okay a lot of the
expats
would move to saudi and go in their
compounds yeah close compound closed
area
they don't blend in with the locals
because many of them when they came here
they get scary
or dangerous thoughts that they are not
friendly they are don't like foreigners
like that right like these things so
they came here scared so they don't want
to blame them right
okay so they afraid of blending in with
people but
some of them when they when they get in
touch with some locals they get a good
feedback but they're very few right
should i should i be scared
[Music]
mubarak what do you think of all these
changes there's so many changes so
quickly here
very nice very good
very good i'm agree with this it's
it's must be before that
times yeah before that 25 years
because
my
youth
times
without this thing yeah okay we traveled
aboard to buying something we didn't
find it here now right
it change every day and you don't know
what's coming i don't know what's coming
but i'm sure
we are going to the right way
to the right track very good to get
people chance
to know about saudi arabia to know about
islam about real islam yeah
you know sometimes
[Music]
in another countries some people
make something
effect for islam
and people who they know about this
thing yeah this is islam but it's not
yeah when you come to saudi arabia you
find the people you talk to the people
yeah you as you
think now you also have in saudi arabia
yeah
you
you will change your image about saudi
arabia for sure and you will use word of
mouth for the people thank you my friend
hope to meet you again
inshallah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
let's check it out
[Music]
[Music]
uh aerospace administration and
operations okay and it was a great
experience actually
it's very very different from here yeah
so you had to know the culture there
experience like with the people
[Music]
how does it feel it's perfect
yeah i want to go back there yeah you
want to visit to visit yeah for sure
you're happy with how saudi is right
yeah for sure
we're getting like
very modernized
you're a pro
thank you brotherhood welcome it's my
second country
yeah yeah yeah i feel that son
we've been chatting we've had a great
conversation so you in public you always
wear a full abaya
and that's a choice yeah this is my
choice yeah cool this is my choice that
choice my family
can't it's my choice
this is
you're a doctor yeah
i thought you were a lawyer yeah
and a doctor yeah
wow a superwoman
professor
professor-in-law and a doctor what kind
of doctor
[Music]
eye doctor
[Music]
wow
it's been a very rewarding experience
and i've met so many cool warm people
and i thought before it would be sort of
hard because tourists were just allowed
here for the first time so i thought
maybe it'd be closed and hard but it was
open
and warm
and
very educational
so thank you thank you saudi people
thank you welcome to saudia
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you